yeah hey good to be here I heard here I
was I had a real chatty driver oh I hate
that would it be nice if there was a
small talk option on the app you know
but there isn't so you gotta really find
your own way to quiet the guy I like to
scare him and now he's like yeah but
this traffic what he thinks causing this
I'm like probably the Jews he's like all
right it's quiet ride yeah I'm staying
in a West Hollywood very gay area which
I like big fan of the gays thanks for
coming out yeah big fan I feel like gay
guys just a little better than us the
only progressive non violent you never
meet any violent gay guys there's no gay
gangs that would just be a musical yeah
I have the worst gaydar on the planet I
can't tell who's gay my friends always
bragging about his gaydar we'll go out
he's like he's gay he's gay he's gay I'm
like well that's not that impressive I
mean we're at a gay bar you weren't too
impressed with your gaydar start
pointing out gay babies now that's
impressive like see that kid
breastfeeding over there between you and
me he's miserable
I'm not gay seeing a lady my girlfriend
she's obsessed with murder shows like
Dateline Forensic Files and she caught
me watching like two seconds of gay porn
she flipped out she was like what the
hell is this I was like will you watch
murder
isn't that way worse
he's just to be 11:6 your things the
first commandment is sitting on the list
she was like what do you want to do this
I was like well do you want to kill me
she was like oh shut up I'm just
watching this so I know what to do if
ever get in that situation I'm like well
maybe that's why I'm watching gay porn
yeah she's like oh that's ridiculous
this is a reenactment
well so is this this guy's not really a
real estate broker yeah you guys are a
fun crowd you know a lot of crowds now
very sensitive everybody's so offended
these days words I always get jealous
when people get offended they go hey
that joke offended me I'm like wow I
wish I cared about anything as much you
cared about that joke what's it like to
feel the only feeling I really get is
loneliness I feel very lonely as a guy
who doesn't get offended offended people
like get together they make signs they
protest on effect we don't get together
never see a bunch of unoffending people
outside of a university like well look
where it's gotten us the whole country
feels angry we're all pent up I got
white supremacist protests all the time
hate groups now you're allowed to be
hateful in America as long as you're not
specific you know if you go I hate
Jewish people every goes oh my god what
a bigoted prejudice but if you go I hate
people every goes tell me about it
oh yeah people are angry man I had one
of those white lives matter rallies go
by my house the other day I freaked out
then I realized uh it's just a half
marathon yeah women are going through a
lot right now women having a real moment
you know men are nervous these days men
are scared looking like creeps have you
noticed that what a woman post a picture
on Facebook it's mostly women commenting
like you're beautiful you're gorgeous
you're sexy a gal be like cool hat but
hey you gotta listen ladies fellas you
gotta listen like a friend of mine she's
like a big feminist she's like I have a
full bush cuz that's how I was born I
was like holy hell you were born with a
full bush wow that is a terrifying baby
not the umbilical cord
I can't find it also that baby's gay
yeah some guys just like whipping it out
that's wild
yeah I think guys get confused cuz
ladies sometimes you like a penis so I
think guys think hey she like won last
night why wouldn't you like won by the
copy machine women are so complex cuz I
think generally speaking men are a
little more constant you know like men
like boobs
we like boobs across the board no boob
in the bedroom
great boob on the bus also great penis
in the bedroom great penis on the bus
call the police nobody's calling the
police on a boob you see a boob out in
the while it's like seeing a deer you're
like
it's majestic
and your friend walks up hey look at
that a boob you're like aah you spooked
it thanks a lot
[Applause]
you